- [Kelly] So, you just
wrapped "The Good Place."
- Yeah, we did.
- Great show.
Do you have any favorite memories?
- Thank you.
All of them are, all the moments
were just great memories.
I mean, I get to work
with like the best people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- TV legend Ted Danson.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, right?
- Super mom Kristen Bell.
But like most of my memories are with Ted,
and like he's just, you
know, the biggest goofball.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like especially when the sun comes down
and the moon's out.
Like and there's a lot of
sugar that goes around on set.
- Oh, I was like, does
he become a werewolf?
What's happening?
I was like, okay.
- Close, almost.
Like there was this moment
where me and my other,
you had him on the show, so
Will, William Jackson Harper.
- Yes, yeah.
- We were just having
a conversation with Ted
and we were just fooling around
and then I was talking to Will
and then I hear a noise
over in Ted's corner.
And then like a gurgling breathing noise.
- Oh.
- And then I just look
at Ted and, you know,
like are you okay?
And then we go about our business.
And then I hear it again.
And then I look closer.
And then there's like
something like red and gooey
up Ted's nose.
And then he takes a breath.
- What?
- And then he goes (snorting quickly),
and then he snorts out
this Swedish fish gummy.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
This is a 70-year-old man doing this.
Yeah.
- Well, I'd be like, why did you do that?
I don't care, I'm just in.
Like that's so funny.
- Yeah.